[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and midnight mass is a
midnight masterpiece the show is a 10
out of 10 for me and i feel like
starting a fan club for mike flanagan as
he's completely knocked out of the park
with his brand new horror show there's
so much to sink your teeth into and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the plot ending the easter
eggs and all of the double meanings
within it full spoilers ahead so if you
haven't seen it then i suggest you get
out of this video in the neck of time if
you enjoy it then please smash the
thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe so there isn't any bad blood
between us without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into
midnight mass
okay so mike flanagan has done a lot of
projects i've absolutely loved oculus
doctor sleep and horning of hill house
are all classics in my eyes with the
latter being one of my favorite tv shows
of all time when the haunting of blind
mana was announced i was extremely
excited for it but unfortunately i was
very disappointed and found it to be a
show that was a retread of the
aforementioned series without any of the
ingenuity that made it really stand out
however midnight mass is incredible and
it quickly put me at ease and reminded
me why i love this guy so much this week
it was revealed that flanagan has been
planning the entire series for over 10
years and nods towards it have appeared
as easter eggs in his previous projects
midnight mass is the name of a book in
both gerald's game and also hush the
blair bonnet even reads for the 512
souls on sleepy crockett and church put
riley face to face with a terrifying
secret the eyes of the undead also turn
very similar to the eyes of the true
knot and it's clear for flanagan that
there's a lot at stake here now in the
first part of the video i am going to be
breaking down the plot of the series
just to add some context but if you want
to skip ahead to the ending then time
codes will be linked below anyway we
open on the symbol of the ichthys which
was created after christ multiplied fish
and loaves of bread in order to feed 5
000 people this idea of a symbol tied to
christianity is quickly juxtaposed by
the horrific crash that starts the
season and it certainly sets up the idea
that we will be facing several themes
such as religion which will be
interlaced with death in real life we've
seen the horrors of what religion can
lead to in the likes of things like
jonestown which similar this season
ended up with those indoctrinated
sibbing the kool-aid after they were
told to end their lives by an authority
figure it all begins with riley a man
who caused the aforementioned crash
thanks to his drinking which led to the
death of a young lady named tara beth
after serving four years in prison he
returns home to crockett island a
backwards fishing community struggling
to stay relevant in an ever-changing
world riley attempted to escape his life
destined to be a fisherman by entering
the world of tech but alas he would end
up back from whence he came he's an
atheist having read every single
religious text from every religion and
he very much sees life as a waste of
time that sucks worse than a vampire
this is what makes the show so layered
and no that's not a garlic pun but it
might well it is yeah it is now usually
religious horror is explored simply
through the eyes of christianity but in
midnight mass many different viewpoints
are shown through riley's atheism
there's a lot of examples such as a
sheriff's unwavering belief in honor of
his wife in islam and bev dolores and
bridges do-gooder who carries a hatred
of anything that isn't christian riley
is clearly wracked with guilt and over
the course of the series he must come to
terms with what he did his own mortality
and how his family and neighbors view
him he tries to adjust to life on the
island but tara beth watches over him
never letting him forget at night he
dreams that he's out on a boat in the
middle of the ocean and we'll talk about
how the idea of life being but a dream
is paid off in this imagery later now
life on the island mainly focuses around
the same patrick's church and the core
faith of each character is explored in
great detail jump scares are swapped
valenti monologues and discussions which
are delivered expertly faith is the key
as the show rumbles on and we meet each
character such as sheriff hassan an nypd
veteran pushed out of the force due to
racism there's also aaron who wants to
embrace religion as well as a mysterious
new priest called father paul who
arrives after telling us that the last
one fell gravely ill now as soon as i
saw the large chest and the cats being
eaten i said that it would be [ __ ]
vampires those who read bram stoker's
dracula will know that the vampire
arrived on the coast of whitby in a
chest just like this and if you visited
the fishing village you'll know it's a
similar sort of setup to what we see in
the show the cathedral lair looms of the
entire area much like the church in this
and though flanagan isn't beating us
over the head with the references it's
clear he's giving nods to the most
famous vampire story of all time paul is
later revealed to be pruitt who traveled
on a religious pilgrimage but due to his
dementia he got lost and came across a
vampire believing it was an angel he
cried out for help and the beast fed on
his blood which restored him and then
healed him it's important to know that
communion is very much seen as drinking
the blood of christ and it nicely ties
together to show how that can be
subverted vampires of course need
familiars in order to travel out into
the world and pruitt very much becomes
the angels now upon his return to the
island it's hidden that we are facing
the end of days as a gigantic storm
rolls in the rainwashes of the bodies of
cats across the beach which is
reminiscent of the infamous plagues and
riley is adamant that he's seen pruitt
which is brushed away as being shadows
in the dark paul or should i call him
pruitt starts mass explaining how the
island will rise again and over time he
becomes a popular figure on it many are
down on their luck including liza who
was paralyzed by the town drunk joe who
like riley and hassan is seen as an
outsider though it's never confirmed
bevens are poisoning joe's dog and it
seems like she kills paul 2 which
resurrects him we never get this
confirmed for daphne but he seems to die
much like the dog does with blood coming
out of his mouth and of course let me
know below if you disagree now in the
series we learned that if one dies
whilst angel's blood is within their
system then they'll rise up as a vampire
that wants to feast on human flesh there
are a lot of people confused over why
paul could handle the light early on but
at this point he wasn't technically a
vampire he just had vampires blood in
his system
now bev mentioned that the bible speaks
of angels with burning skin and
revelations and both she and paul use
this to justify their actions throughout
the show when revealed to sarah what has
happened she summarizes that the myths
of the angels could come from a blood
disease that creates a drastic need for
iron the sacrament asks worshippers to
take wine said to be the blood of christ
and he himself died and came back three
days later sarah quite rightly explains
this is indeed where christian ritual
could come from and sharing his blood
would mean empowering and curing people
explaining the miracles that are talked
about in the bible we learn that pruitt
has a plan for improving their life by
continuing to use the tainted angel
blood for the sacramental wine
regenerating the cells of those that
came to the church he intends to make
everyone's life better and the healing
properties of it allow lisa to walk
again this miracle brings more people to
the church and thus it gives paul a
bigger flock to infect hints start to
show that something peculiar is going on
as people stop visibly healing riley's
dad's backmans itself his wife no longer
needs glasses and sarah's mother
basically does a benjamin button now it
seems like flanagan has replaced hidden
ghosts for hidden heels and though it
initially seems like good news it also
has adverse effects in that it kills
aaron's baby atheism and faith in an era
of miracles is explored in great detail
with assange struggling to get his child
to follow islam as ali wants to fit in
and choose his faith making this a
multi-layered exploration of what it is
to believe bev is vile towards the
religion and only becomes more and more
emboldened as her idolization of paul
increases someone she was dismissive of
at first after his death paul starts
jonesing hard and he kills joe before
drinking his blood this happens after he
points out the similarities between paul
and a young pruitt and he also pays lip
service to the affair that the latter
was apparently having with sarah's
mother another hint towards an eventual
reveal comes when she said she thought
she saw sarah's dad's face at her
bedroom window but this is brushed away
as being a side effect of her dementia
later on it's revealed that paul is
indeed sarah's father and we learned
that he was peering into houses which is
set up nicely in that moment bev
involves are the town members namely
sturgeon leaves his father and covering
up his death and slowly everyone begins
to get their hands dirty in order to
keep up the sanctity of the church one
night riley on a chance encounter turns
about the rec center and mr x
sorry the angel kills him and turns him
into a creature of the night now if
there's one core message i took away
from this show it's that not everyone is
as virtuous as they claim to be paul
explains to riley what happened and
urges him to follow in his footsteps by
telling him a story about an altar boy
who brought him a dying rat which turns
out to be riley pruitt lied to instill
riley's faith leading to riley having an
unrealistic expectation growing up that
he now has stepped away from there's
also an incredible scene with both riley
and aaron in which they talk about what
they imagine death to be because of his
distrust of the church the former very
much sees nothing at the end whereas
aaron who is grieving her baby imagines
them being embraced by her family in the
afterlife when aaron dies in the show
she changes this thinking and instead
views herself as simply a manifestation
of the universe dreaming of itself and
what life would be like einstein
famously said that energy can either be
created or destroyed and aaron very much
surmises that we are here and then we go
back to the greater whole our
consciousness came from seemingly
nowhere but we all have our own thoughts
and feelings and when we cease to exist
we will return to whatever we were
before it's a beautiful conversation and
it somewhat foreshadows riley's death
which comes not long after now paul
explains he wants to heal a community
but really he's just a self-serving
person who's accepted these awful things
citing scripture is a good reason paul
intends for people to convert to being
an angel and though he says they'll be
welcomed peacefully into this new life
they will all be very much forced to
follow what he says
with aaron riley heads out into the
ocean and explains that this is very
reminiscent of his dream he finally
finds his purpose and riley to me as
someone who had two options he could
have lived for eternity as a
self-serving vampire that would feed
upon others to get his wish or he could
finally break free of this and avoid
hurting the ones that he loved
alcoholism and drunk driving are often
seen as very self-centered acts and the
character doing this in the intro led to
the death of an innocent woman however
it also hurt his family and on top of it
because of this he's lived a life of
misery riley could easily feast upon
aaron at this point but instead he lets
himself burn in the sun and he gives her
the knowledge that she needs to take
down pruitt and his followers this to me
is why he's joined by the spirit of taro
beth at the end who has clearly forgiven
him because he's learned from his
mistakes rather than being alone on the
boat as he was his greatest mistake for
giving him means he can forgive himself
as he passes away it's a very beautiful
mo oh my god oh
this is horrible horrible
however returns back to the island as
the nighttime mass is being prepared for
the easter vigil this is one of the most
popular times for church attendance and
nurse pruitt can recruit more people to
the cause however easter itself is also
about the death and rebirth of christ
which is a theme that's used through the
ceremony aaron plans to work with sarah
and her mother to stop the converted
however they ultimately fail as they
fall in line and head to the church at
the church the attendees are offered up
a cup filled with bev's poison and most
of them willingly end their lives in
order to be reborn however they're
hungry for flesh and the undead turn on
the living which leads to a bloodbath
bev heads out into the night with the
newly converted and they cast judgment
on all killing all of the islanders we
see some of the best sequences in the
show as the rabbit angels go around
feeding and burning everything to the
ground believing that revelations is
upon them we witness bev's twisted view
that god is preparing his believers for
the end of days and that the conversion
will help them in the perpetual night
her truly awful nature is exposed as she
turns on pruitt and won't even feed on
hassan believing his blood to be tainted
the converted have their hubris rune for
themselves by burning most of the places
they could have hidden during the day
and we see aaron sarah and hazan
navigator the only hiding spots left to
bring them down in a blaze of glory it
shows they are truly sinful and just
like lucifer their gift has been taken
away damning them to burn alive come
dawn
and hubris are some of the traits that
god hates the most according to the
bible so he does truly give and take
away in the end for all his sins pruitt
does see the error of his ways and
finally he speaks to his daughter
without the burden of hiding the truth
he realized that he had lost his way and
just before this the fundamental
difference between bevan pruitt was
exposed she saw the church as being an
ark and a base to spread the conversion
but he explains that it was about god
and doing right by his community bev has
taken it to the extreme and she accuses
him of switching to human things and not
the divine in reality the holy felt in
his life has been filled by his daughter
as he can now acknowledge his secret sin
he can finally leave the church which he
wanted to do all these years and end
life on his own terms with his family
around him now one question you might
have is did the angel die as erin lays
there and life slowly starts to drain
out of her she cuts his wings as he
feasts on her neck warren explains that
the angel would need to fly around 30
miles to be the sun which would be very
difficult for it he's unsure if the
angel can make the distance but in the
end we just don't know this creature has
of course survived for centuries i don't
think you can count it out either way
now it's very much shrouding as angel
but i do think that thematically we can
say that it's gone as its life was very
closely tied to the islanders in the
show however there's always the
possibility there that flanagan wants to
do a sequel that he can and he should he
should because this was amazing
he probably won't know because it was
too good don't don't ruin it by doing a
sequel thought again i'll change my mind
now in the end we do have two survivors
in warren and lisa after gaining
chekov's sniper rifle they managed to
flee the island on a boat in order to
wait it out until dawn both were
virtuous with warren abstaining from
drink and lisa is showing forgiveness to
joe sadly it seems like lisa will no
longer be able to walk which is of
course due to the angel blood running
out of her system now it may seem like
it's back to square one but she has
rejected the false prophets something
that the bible has countless verses on
lisa and warren's escape could be looked
at as the rapture escaping the damned
crooked island much like the christians
say how the believers will be saved and
the rest will be left to judgment the
others had twisted their religion to
justify awful things and subverted the
gift they were given showing that humans
had not really changed much from the
original sin the survivors of crockett
saw peace in the sunrise and looked to
wash themselves away in the divine light
of god the bible itself said in luke
because of the tender mercy of our god
whereby the sunshine shall visit us from
the high to give light to those who sit
in darkness and in the shadow of death
to guide our feet in the way of peace
the sun rises symbolic of a new day and
the sins of the past being washed away
we also see the ash of their bodies blow
over the boat and this is very symbolic
of the saying ashes to ashes and dust to
dust which of course pulls from the
bible as they die everyone on the island
sings nearer my god to me and this has
significance for a number of reasons
firstly it contains lyrics about angels
beckoning those on earth into heaven and
how they will finally meet god however
it was also the last song to be played
on the titanic as it and its passengers
sunk into the ocean though it should be
seen as a tragic ending for lisa she has
very much avoided the easy road and
though she is back to being paralyzed
she is still alive unlike all the others
who gave into sin and the temptation of
a better life her defeating this
temptation and breaking away from the
flock is what saves her in the end and
it stands firm as a positive message the
series shows us that the road to hell is
paved with good intentions and though
she could have given in at any point due
to pressure from her parents an
authority figure and her community she
didn't and now she gets to live in the
end it has a very powerful meaning and
overall the show was a stunning work of
acting writing and the betrayal of a
wide range of beliefs this was merged
into a layered and nuanced view on the
spectrum of belief and religion that's a
real page turner i know the phrase page
turner doesn't really work here but you
know what i mean yeah it was you
couldn't stop watching it seven hours no
no breaks for me now it's something that
each viewer will take their own meaning
from just like the good book whilst
midnight mass is a wild departure from
the haunting series and though some may
take time to adjust to it it's an
absolutely outstanding series that can't
praise highly enough it's rare that we
give shows a 10 out of 10 but i think
this deserves it as it's just phenomenal
on every level it's probably my favorite
netflix series of all time and i can't
wait to talk about all the different
themes with you in the comments below
make sure you drop them and as a thank
you we are running a competition right
now and giving away three copies of zack
snyder's dc trilogy on the 30th of
september all you have to do to get it
is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the show we pick the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of the last one on screen right now so
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want someone else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of squid game which will
be linked on screen right now that's
another amazing netflix series you
should check out so hopefully i see you
over there right after this if not then
thank you for sitting through this video
i've been paul you take care yourself
and i'll see you next time peace
you